تزداد وتييرتها وكثافتها كل يوم
هكذا بدا حال العاصمه بعد هجوم ليلي جديد
بالصواريخ والمسيرات
لكن حالها نهارا لم يكن مختلفا هجمه
صاروخيه وانفجارات لم تهدا للتزامن مع عمل
الدفاعات الجويه روعت حياه سكان العاصمه
فهرعوا الى محطات المترو للاحتماء
مشاهد تعيد الى الاذهان صور بدايات الحرب
وربما اصعب اما المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه فافصح عن طبيعه الهجوم
ما يقرب من عشره صواريخ باليستيه اطلقت
خلال الهجوم الجديد على كيف انها على
الاغلب من نوع اسكندر هناك دقائق معدوده
لرصد الصواريخ الباليستيه لحظه اطلاقها
وخصوصا عند اطلاقها من منصات ارضيه
على رؤوس العابرين هنا سقط حطام احد
الصواريخ في واحد من شوارع المدينه لم
تفصح السلطات عن طبيعته بعد ولا عن حجم
الاضرار في مواقع غير هذه استهدفت دون
السماح لنا بتصويرها لحساسيتها الكبيره
ورغم التصريح باصابه شخص فقط واسقاط جميع
الاهداف
ظهر رئيس الاستخبارات متوعدا من يهدد
بلاده
لقد هزمنا اولئك الذين لا زالوا يؤمنون او
يعتقدون او ربما يحلمون بانهم يستطيعون
تهديد بلادنا اما من عايش هذه الهجمات من
السكان فباتوا يعبرون عن حيرتهم اذا
الواقع الجديد
كنا قد اعتدنا على سماع صفاره الانذار في
كييف طيله سنه ونصف من الحرب وظننا ان كل
شيء على ما يرام لكننا الان نفاجئ بحجم
وكثافه الضربات ولم نعد نفهم ما يحدث
تماما
اسئله كثيره يطرحها
بعد هذه الهجمات الجويه المكثفه نحو
عاصمتهم ومدنهم في كل الاوقات الى متى
ستستمر والى اي مدى يمكن ان تصل وحتى متى
ستتمكنوا الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه من
الاستمرار في اعتراضها في ظل تحذيرات
رسميه من محاولات استنزافها تتعدد تساؤلات
لكن وحتى هذه اللحظه
تغيب الاجابات حسن مسعود الجزيره كيف